So you've created a web app using Flask, Django, FastAPI, or even Emmet.
It works great on your machine.
How do you get it out to the world?
Well, you'll need a production ready web server.
Of course, on this episode, we have Giovanni Barriari to tell us about his
relatively new server named Grianian.
It promises better performance and much better consistency than many of
the more well-known ones today.
This is Talk Python to Me, episode 463.
Are you ready for your host, Darius?
You're listening to Michael Kennedy on Talk Python to Me.
Live from Portland, Oregon, and this segment was made with Python.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the
podcast using @talkpython, both on fosstodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified
about upcoming shows and be part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by Neo4j.
It's time to stop asking relational databases to do more than they were made
for and simplify complex data models with graphs, check out the sample FastAPI
project and see what Neo4j, a native graph database, can do for you.
Find out more at talkpython.fm/neo4j.
And it's also brought to you by us over at Talk Python Training.
Did you know that we have over 250 hours of Python courses?
Yeah, that's right.
Check them out at talkpython.fm/courses.
In fact, I want to tell you about our latest course we just released last week,
Getting Started with NLP and Spacy.
This one is written by Vincent Wormerdam.
You may know him from many of his educational projects and channels, but
he also worked at Explosion AI, the makers of Spacy, so it's safe to say he knows
his stuff when it comes to NLP and Spacy.
If you have text you need to analyze, pull entities from, understand the
sentiment, and so much more, then Spacy is one of the best frameworks out there for
this.
And now we have an awesome course you can use to get way better at NLP.
During the course, you need a fun project, right?
Well, Vincent uses the past nine years of Talk Python transcripts, along with a few
data science programming bits of magic, to process them all with Spacy and ask
awesome questions like, "Which frameworks are we talking about over the years?"
Sign up for the course at talkpython.fm/spacy.
And if you hurry and get it in the month of May, 2024, we're doing a special 10%
off to celebrate the launch.
That's talkpython.fm/spacy.
The link is in your podcast player show notes.
Enjoy the course.
Now onto that interview.
Giovanni, welcome to Talk Python.
Hello, Michael.
Thank you for having me on the show.
It's great to have you on the show.
Some people you learn about just from like their public speaking or their writing,
and other people you meet through their projects, right?
I got to know you through Granian, your Rust-based Python and other thing, web
server, that I thought was really awesome.
Started playing with it and we started talking on GitHub around some ideas.
And then here you are, sort of explored more, learn more about some of your
frameworks that like you'd created from.
So I'm excited to talk about Emmet, Granian, and a bunch of other things that
you built, like kind of all to go together in a big mix there.
Yeah, I'm excited as well.
Yeah, it should be a lot of fun.
Before we get into all the details of all that stuff, you know, just
tell us a bit about yourself.
I'm Giovanni Barillari.
I actually born in Italy, but today I'm living in Vienna, in Austria.
I'm actually a physicist.
So yeah, I graduated in physics at the university.
And let's say I started working as a software engineer, focused especially
on web software pretty soon after the university.
So it's like 10 years something.
I'm working as a software engineer, also like as a cipher diabetes engineer.
So let's just say I'm quite like on the backend side of the things usually.
And I also started, I actually started like contributing to open source software
projects, even before actually starting working as a software engineer.
And particularly I started like contributing to the Web2Py project.
It's a quite old project by Massimo Di Piero.
And yeah, today I'm working as a cipher diabetes engineer for Sentry.
I bet that pretty much of the people know about Sentry.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I didn't even know that you worked for Sentry until just a few minutes ago.
That's pretty awesome.
Obviously people know Sentry, they're big supporters of the show and sponsor
some of the episodes, but yeah.
How's it like to work at Sentry?
Must be fun.
Well, it's super nice.
A lot of talented people.
They're super nice.
It's a really nice environment to be within.
So yeah, I'm super happy.
Yeah.
Awesome.
What does a software reliability engineer do?
So let's say it might be a complicated question because like actually
the original title comes from Google.
So let's say is kind of related to infrastructure and
monitoring in software.
So let's say to simplify that it's about be sure that everything runs smoothly
with no incidents and stuff like that.
I see.
Make sure you can monitor bugs, slowdowns, work on failover type of
situations, that kind of stuff.
Exactly.
I imagine you probably use Sentry to monitor Sentry for reliability.
Is that right?
Yes.
We have this project called Sentry for Sentry.
Okay.
Which is like a separated Sentry instance that monitors the actual SAS
instance of Sentry.
That's pretty interesting because of course, if Sentry went down, you're
using it to monitor it.
Yeah.
Everyone else uses Sentry to monitor their thing.
Then it's not about when their code goes down, it doesn't affect it.
But when your code goes down, it might actually affect your ability to know
that it's down.
So a separate copy, that's wild.
Okay.
I hadn't even thought of that.
Exactly.
Super cool.
All right.
Now, first of all, there's a little bit of love out in the audience for your
whole larger project, Emmet.
So Tushar says, "Did you say Emmet?"
Emmet is amazing, which is super cool.
Tools like that encourage him to work on his dev tooling, which is really great.
Before we get into the details of that though, why create another web framework?
I don't mean this in a negative way.
It's just like there's Flask and Django and then we have FastAPI and so on.
So why not just go, "Oh, I'm just going to use this one."
Like what inspired you to go, "I think I'll make one of them."
So I think we should go back a bit in time because actually like this year will be
like the 10th birthday of like Emmet.
So let's just say it's like a long time.
So it's not that new.
Okay.
Out there.
Yeah.
I see.
So originally it was released as, it had like a different name.
It was called Wepi and I changed the name in 2020 I think, like with the, when I
moved from synchronous paradigm to the asynchronous one.
So let's say at the time I designed Wepi, so the original version in 2014, the main
thing was about, so that time it was like the time of Ruby on Rails being super
popular and I originally started working in web development using Ruby on Rails.
And when comparing, let's say the amount of, let's say batteries included in the
box of Ruby on Rails to the Python ecosystem.
So let's say that the major competitor at that point in time was Django, but let's
say the feeling I got from Django at that time compared to Ruby on Rails was completely
different in a sense that I found myself like spending much more time on building
stuff compared to Ruby on Rails.
And this is also what bring me to the Web2Py project or to Py community, because
it was in a sense, pretty similar in some of the design decisions with RAR.
And, but at the same time, like once you start contributing to a web framework,
you have time to like to dig into a lot of the internals and decisions.
And so Web2Py at that time, so I used Web2Py to build my first, the code behind
my first startup actually, and it had quite a lot of scaling issues at that time.
So let's say at that point in time, I just was looking out for the options and I
started like digging into the code internals of Django and also Flask, which, I mean, I
really loved like the Flask approach of things, but at the same time it was so
micro.
Yeah.
I mean, like to build an actual project, it required like to have like tons of
extensions and other pieces, let's say other libraries to add it to the project
that, yeah, I think like I ended up just, you know, saying, okay, let's just
rebuild Web2Py the way I want it.
And that's eventually how WebP came out and today Emmet.
Yeah.
That's pretty much the story behind it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I didn't realize it went that far back.
How about Granian?
Is that newer?
Yeah.
Granian is, I think like the first public release is like from one year ago or
something.
Yeah.
And I, because I learned about Emmet through Granian and like, oh, it's kind
of all, probably all the same project.
I didn't realize the history.
Why the new name?
Why Emmet?
So the thing was that to support, let's say the upgrade between WebP and Emmet.
So since like all the interfaces has to be changed to support like async code,
the idea was to provide, let's say a quick way to, to do that.
Meaning that to make it possible for developers to, you know, install like a
new version of WebP and getting like everything broken because of, you know,
the new interfaces.
So yeah, I just decided to, you know, changing the interface and also changing
like the package name in order to say, sure.
Okay.
If you want to upgrade, you can upgrade safely.
Otherwise, it's like a super mega version change.
Not only do you change the version, but you change the name.
Yeah.
I see.
Exactly.
That's interesting.
All right.
Well, let's dive into it.
So I like the title Emmet, the web framework for inventors.
And yeah, maybe give us a sense of like, what are some of the core features of
Emmet and what are your goals with building it?
From an API perspective.
The idea was to have like all in one, let's say framework to build web
application, all in one, let's say in a sense of, again, when the project
actually started.
So like even 10 years after that, I still usually prefer to develop web
projects without relying too much on front-end frameworks.
So this is like a big, let's say a preamble to the thing.
Like this is originally from an era where like front-end web framework
didn't exist.
Like, I think it was just AngularJS and maybe Ember at that time.
Yeah.
You're basically describing my life in 2024.
So I'm a big fan of the server-side frameworks, you know?
Thanks, Jack.
Yeah.
Also because like, it seems sometimes that we reinvent like a lot of stuff to catch
up, like the beginning at the end.
Like, yeah, I felt like all of the theme about, you know, server-side rendering
with front-end frameworks and server-side render components and all that kind of
stuff.
So sometimes it just feels, you know, we're getting back to the origin.
But yeah, so the idea behind Emmet is to have like all in one solution to develop
web applications.
So you have all the standard features you have with the web framework.
So like routing and middlewares and that kind of stuff.
You have an ORM, you have a templating system plus a few, let's say, tools
embedded within.
So for instance, it's very easy to use, I don't know, sessions or to have an
authentication system.
It's all like provided inside the box.
So yeah, the idea was to have like, let's say a battery of tools, like in one place
to do the most common things when you start developing a web application.
Yeah, very nice.
So yeah, like you said, it has an ORM built in and it feels, I guess, SQL
alchemy-ish in a sense, but not exactly the same.
Or Django ORM would be, you know, another way in some ways there.
Yeah, I think it's more near to SQL alchemy in that sense.
You tend to have like an API for using Python objects to build queries rather than
how to say, use like a lot of strings attributes like you usually tends to do in
Django.
Yeah, I mean, it's more close to SQL alchemy in that sense.
I think like the major difference with the ORMs out there is that the model class
you define are not like, so when you, for example, select records from the database,
the single, let's say rows you select are not instances of the model class.
So let's say like the model class acts more like management class.
Like a schema definition sort of thing.
Yeah, I mean, it does like a lot of helpers top of that, but yeah, I think like
it's definitely the major difference between like the vast majority of ORMs out
there for Python when you usually have like the model class, which is also like
the class of all the records you select and work on from the database.
Yeah.
So what do you get back in this world here?
What do you get if you do a query, like in your example on the homepage, you have a
time traveler.
So what do you get back when you get a group of them, a set of them?
So you get like a different class.
So there's like a separated class.
Every model has, it's called like row class.
So it's an instance of that class.
And this design, it's mostly made for two reasons.
Like the first one is performance in a sense, meaning that when you select records
or operate on records, it avoids to, you know, fulfill like all those objects with
the actual model class attributes or functions or methods.
And the validation and stuff.
Yeah.
And on the other end was also to kind of remind to the developer that he is working
with actual data from the database and not like real Python objects in a sense,
which is, yeah.
Yeah.
I think like in the years is like the first reason why people tend to object against
ORMs.
So those two were the main reasons behind this design.
It's something like, you know, in the between of an ORM and just some
database abstraction layer.
This portion of Talk Python to Me is brought to you by Neo4j.
Do you know Neo4j?
Neo4j is a native graph database.
And if the slowest part of your data access patterns involves computing
relationships, why not use a database that stores those relationships directly in the
database?
Unlike your typical relational one, a graph database lets you model the data the way it
looks in the real world, instead of forcing it into rows and columns.
It's time to stop asking a relational database to do more than they were made for
and simplify complex data models with graphs.
If you haven't used a graph database before, you might be wondering about common use
cases.
You know, what's it for?
Here are just a few.
Detecting fraud, enhancing AI, managing supply chains, gaining a 360 degree view of
your data, and anywhere else you have highly connected data.
To use Neo4j from Python, it's a simple pip install Neo4j.
And to help you get started, their docs include a sample web app demonstrating how to
use it both from Flask and FastAPI.
Find it in their docs or search GitHub for Neo4j Movies Application Quickstart.
Developers are solving some of the world's biggest problems with graphs.
Now it's your turn.
Visit talkpython.fm/neo4j to get started.
That's talkpython.fm/neo, the number four, and the letter J.
Thank you to Neo4j for supporting Talk Python To Me.
I like the query syntax.
You know, people visit the homepage, you'd see something like time travel dot where,
then lambda of T goes to T dot return equal equal true.
And while some of the ORMs let you write code in terms of like the class fields or
whatever, it's never looked quite right because you're working with, say, the
static value out of the class.
Whereas what you really are trying to talk about is the instance level of the record,
right?
So instead of saying T, you'd say time travel dot return, but we'd never test that
because it's the global value of it, right?
And stuff like that.
Or you just use strings, which is basically in my mind, no good.
But what's cool, you know, also, do you want to do an OR or an AND?
And then what weird thing do you import to do the OR?
And like, you know, how do you wrap the query and all that kind of stuff where if
it's a lambda, you can just express the conditions how you want.
Yeah.
That's pretty much the idea.
So like to use, you know, special methods from Python objects and translate those
expression like in actually SQL code.
So yeah.
Nice.
For my apps, I have a combination of Beanie and Mongo engine, depending on which one
you're talking about.
And for Mongo engine, you do things that are pretty funky.
Like if you want to say greater than, you would say time travel dot, I don't know,
it doesn't have a value, but age.
I'll say there's an age, like time travel dot age, underscore, underscore GT equals
value.
And you're like, well, it's not, it's not equal to it.
And it's not that that's not the name of it, but, but okay.
That, I guess that means, you know what I mean?
Like there's a real weird way it's like jammed into a syntax, whereas like here
you just say greater than whatever.
Right.
Yeah.
It's like the same of, of it's one of the things I dislike still today of Django or
Ram in that sense.
I mean, it has like a lot of, a lot more capabilities because for instance, like
when you want to represent like complex queries, it tends to be more powerful in
that sense, meaning that special methods are limited.
So at some point you start making custom methods.
So like, I don't know, starts with, for example.
Yeah.
Starts with, or in this set or the set includes this and something like that.
Right.
Exactly.
So I think, yeah, there are pros and cons in both, let's say approaches.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
So we have a lot to talk about, even though all this code fits on one screen.
The other part is to define an endpoint.
This is about an API, right?
So you have an async def, which is awesome.
Supports async and await.
I think it's super valuable.
Yeah.
One note is that your Ram is still synchronous.
So what about that?
Are you planning on adding an async thing or are you just saying it's just synchronous?
So it's like a very long story in a sense, because like I started asking myself the
same question like several years ago.
And I think like at some point probably I will end up doing that in the same way.
SQLAlchemy did that.
Even if I remember like a super nice blog post from the author of SQLAlchemy stating
that asynchronous code and databases are not the best way to use that.
So yeah, let's say like in the last few years I just waited in a way to see what
everyone else was doing.
But yeah, I think like at some point it will be inevitable in a sense.
I just don't feel the time has come yet.
So we'll see.
Yeah.
Cool.
And then I guess the last thing to talk about is you have a decorated app.route.
Pretty straightforward.
Yeah.
But then you also have a @service.json.
What's the stacker to do?
So you can think about that decorator like the service decorator as like the JSONify
function in Flask.
So yeah, in Emmet you have like both the JSON service and the XML service because like in
old times I had to write stuff to talk with XML and points and stuff like that.
So.
Yeah.
So yeah, it's just an easy way to wrap and say everything that returns from this
function, just serializing JSON or XML or whatever.
If I return rather than a response, just return a dictionary and it'll do the
serialization, right?
Exactly.
Nice.
And the audience asks, does it generate an open API documentation?
Like auto, does it automatically generate documentation?
So from standard routes?
No.
There's an extension though, meaning that if you plan to design REST let's say
APIs with Emmet, there's an extension for that.
It's called Emmet REST, which let's say gives you like more tools to structure
your routes and serialization and deserialization and all that kind of stuff.
And that extension also brings open API documentation generation.
Eventually let's say the open API documentation generation will come
also to plain routes in Emmet, but there's quite a few design implied to do that.
Meaning that so Emmet it's like not designed to have a strong type system
because again, it comes from the days where like typing.
That didn't exist.
Was not.
Yeah.
So let's say that for instance, for frameworks like FastAPI, which are
practically designed on top of something like Pydantic, so you have like a strong
type system, so everything that comes in and out from the majority of routes you
write has types and so it's really easy for the framework to inspect the code and
understand what's going on.
On let's say general frameworks like Emmet where you, I mean, you might have
like, I don't know, HTML routes or other kinds of stuff going on.
There's no, let's say design behind that to support in the first play, like strong
typing.
So yeah, making like open API documentation out of standard Emmet routes involves
like quite a lot of decisions.
So yeah, we'll see.
We'll see.
Yeah.
Okay.
Very cool.
Yeah.
We'll come back and talk about Emmet REST in a minute.
That's one of the fun things.
It also has a WebSocket support, right?
Yep.
Okay.
Absolutely.
WebSockets are these things that I'm always like, man, they're so cool and you
can do all this interesting stuff.
And then I never, ever, ever have a use case for it in my world.
I just haven't yet.
And so I'm like, well, they're very cool, but I don't have it yet.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I'm not building Slack.
The thing is that usually like when you work with WebSockets, it's also pretty
common that you need some broadcast facility.
Yeah.
So usually you want to do channels or that kind of stuff, which usually tends
to involve like other software, like you usually have Redis or something like that
to, in order to, since Python is not exactly good in, let's say, managing
threads or communicating across different processes, that's probably why it's not
so easy in the Python world to actually rely on WebSockets a lot.
I don't know, for instance, if you take like languages like, I don't know,
Elixir or you have like tons of stuff based on the fact that everything is
actually communicating over Socket.
So, yeah.
And I think like one single thing to say on WebSockets, it's, I think EMMET is
the only, or one of the few frameworks that allows you to write middlewares with
Sockets, so you can, so if you have like your chain of middlewares on the
application, you can also define behaviors for the same middlewares to behave on
WebSockets.
So you can probably reuse like a lot of code.
Like, I don't know if you are in a WebSocket and need to talk with the
database, you can use the same middleware for the database connection you use on
the standard request.
So I think that's might be worth noting.
Yeah, absolutely.
Another thing that's interesting that I don't see in a lot of ORMs, they kind of
just leave it to the, well, in SQL, so you write it, is aggregation, right?
The aggregation stuff you have here is pretty interesting where you do a bunch
of calculation type stuff in the database and then get a, sort of the results back.
Right?
So here you can say like, select, I'm talking about an event, like event.location,
get the counts and then group by this thing, order by that, having these sort of
properties.
That's, that's pretty unique.
I don't see that in a lot of ORMs.
Yeah, I think like you can do pretty much the same with the SQL alchemy, but
probably like the syntax is less sugary, let's say.
I mean, again, this design comes from the fact that with my first startup, we had to
do like a lot of aggregation over the database.
And so that's why I wrote all of that, you know.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah.
Nice.
I, you know, I'm familiar with it from all the MongoDB stuff that I've done,
that like that, the big aggregation pipeline over there as well.
Yeah.
I'm also familiar, like I'm not a huge fan of Mongo though, probably because like
being an SRE, like making Mongo reliable is like a mess sometimes.
So I think it depends on how people rely on it.
Right.
Yeah.
For me, it's been absolutely, I've run my stuff on over 10 years and it's been
perfect, however, that's because I use a lot of structured code to talk to Mongo
from one tech stack, right?
But if some people are using dictionaries to talk to it, other people using this
framework, other people using that framework, then the lack of the schema
structure, I think becomes a problem.
So I think it really depends on how you use it, but yeah, I hear what you're
saying for sure.
I think that that's not even necessarily a Mongo challenge.
That's a document database challenge generally, right?
Yeah.
Just Mongo is primarily the way people do document databases.
I tended to like use it for separate stuff.
So in several projects I worked on, I had like, for instance, like the main
database with Oscars, for instance, like another database with Mongo for specific
stuff, maybe stuff you don't need transactions on, or maybe you want to
store like time series data or, you know, that kind of stuff.
So for that, I think it's really cool.
Yeah.
Nice.
All right.
I guess one final thing here that is worth covering, then we'll, I want to dive
into a gradient as well as the template syntax.
So you've got your own template syntax.
That's kind of like, that's not a syntax.
You tell people about it.
You tell them about it.
Yeah.
So the inflating system embedded in Emmet is called Renoir.
And the idea behind it is to don't have a syntax at all.
So the, the idea behind Emmet template system was why?
So the question I had is like, why do I have to learn a new language to write
server-side rendered templates?
Like why came out?
Yeah.
And those languages are, yeah.
And they're very, very Python like, but they're not Python.
Exactly.
So I just said, well, I guess I'll try to do just Python, you know, wrap it in the
same brackets every other templating language has.
So it's just plain Python.
You can do pretty much everything you can do in Python.
You can even do imports inside.
Not that I suggest to do that, but you can still, you can do that.
Are you, you'll go create PHP people.
Come on now.
Exactly.
The only, let's say major difference from standard Python code is that you have to
write the pass keyword after a block of code.
So if you write like a for loop or an if statement, the template engine has to know
when that block ends, given that Python relies on indentation to understand like
that, but in templates, you don't have like the same in the initial level you have in
Python.
So that's the only major difference from plain Python code, plus a few, let's say
keyword added to the game.
So you have extend and include in order to extend and include.
So there are partial templates, let's say, and, and blocks.
That's it.
Right.
Blocks for the layout sections, right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's really nice.
I like the idea.
I'm sure there are people listening that'd be like, I would like to try this stuff out,
but I've got 10,000 lines of Jinja or I've got 10,000 lines of chameleon or yeah.
Yeah.
I know.
Whatever.
What's the story?
I mean, I'm working in the office with Armin Ronaker every day.
So the amount of Jinja code we have in Sentry is like huge.
So yeah, I perfectly understand the point.
I don't have like, let's say marketing line for selling Renoir.
It's just something that I, so today I'm so, I'm equitably familiar to, to Jinja
templates and Renoir templates.
I'd say it really depends on how you usually structure your application code.
So I think one good way to try out for Renoir is if you tend to don't use a lot
like Jinja filters or stuff like that, that might be a good case scenario to try
it out Renoir.
Yeah.
But of course it has to be like a new project because.
Converting, I mean, there's no sense into moving, translating code from one
system to another once you pick.
It's not super different.
I think you change an end if to a pass, for example, or end for into a pass.
But I was thinking more, is there a way to use Jinja within Emmet?
Right.
Instead of using Renoir.
I mean, there's no plain, there's no read extension for that.
But I mean, if you create like a Jinja instance over the application, you can
call it in your roots.
You can even create a middleware for that.
So I think it's pretty easy also to set up Emmet to work with Jinja.
Yeah, I would think so.
I created a chameleon FastAPI, which lets you basically put a decorator on FastAPI
endpoints.
And it does chameleon template rendering with the dictionary instead of rest
It wasn't that much.
You basically just have to juggle it from behind.
So I imagine you could probably, someone could create a Jinja decorator, like you
have service.json, like a template.Jinja or whatever, something like that.
Right?
Probably.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
That said, I'm not a fan of Jinja.
I think it's overly complicated.
So I'm not encouraged, I'm not suggesting it, but the reality is, even as much as I've
tried to fight against it, is that the majority of Python web HTML, dynamic HTML
is done in Jinja these days.
Right.
Which.
Yeah, probably true.
Yeah.
You kind of got to live in that, that space, even if you don't want to.
All right.
And let's talk about the thing that I opened and talked about at the opening is
Granian.
Where's Granian gone?
There we go.
So this is how, as I said, I got to learn about this framework and what you're doing
and stuff with Granian.
Tell us about Granian.
And before, as a way to sort of kick this off, Cody, who I've had on the show before
from Litestar says, thanks for the work on Granian.
I've had an excellent time using it with Litestar.
Litestar is also awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks to Cody.
So tell us about it.
Yeah.
So as the description suggests, it's just an HTTP server for Python application.
So it does the same scope of a Uvicorn, G-Unicorn, Hypercorn and all that libraries.
The main difference compared to every other HTTP server for Python application is that
it's not written in Python.
It's written in Rust.
And it supports natively both BoozG and A-S-G-I.
So both synchronous and asynchronous applications.
Plus a new protocol I also wrote with Granian, which is called R-S-G-I.
But the only existing framework using it that I am aware of is Emmet, indeed.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot of things that are nice about this.
And I have actually most of the things, including Talk Python itself running on
Granian, which is pretty cool.
So.
Cool.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
So single correct HTTP implementation.
Sounds awesome.
Support for version one, two and three, I guess when it's ratified, right?
Yeah.
So HTTP/3, let's say since Granian is actually based on a Rust library, which is
called Hyper, which is a super cool library, it's like vastly adopted, like
everywhere in the world, like, I don't know how many thousands, hundreds of
thousands of libraries in the Rust ecosystem use it.
It is used in Cloudflare for a lot of their production systems.
So super strong library, but yes, it doesn't yet support HTTP/3.
So yeah, I guess when Hyper will support HTTP/3, that could be
easily added those two Granian.
Right.
That's cool.
Yeah.
With these things like GNU-Core, and you've then got to also integrate
U-Vehicle and workers and you kind of have a lot of stuff at play, right?
So here you've just got one thing, which is cool.
Yeah.
I mean, like I tended to find annoying the fact that if you want, like to squeeze
out like performance out of U-Vehicle, you usually need to pile up different
libraries together, like, Oh wait, I need to add the HTTP tools dependency.
So it can use as like the C written parsers for HTTP.
Oh wait, and probably I want some process management.
So I need also a GNU-Core.
Yeah.
It's not super easy, like for starters, at least.
I guess maybe we should just set the stage a little bit for the people that
don't live and breathe Python web deployment, apologies.
So typically you would have something like Nginx or caddy that
browser actually talks to.
And then behind the scenes, you set up those, let's just say Nginx to when
there's a request for a dynamic content or Python based content, as opposed
to like a CSS file or something, then it will talk to this category of servers
that then maybe is juggling multiple processes so that it can increase the
scalability of your Python apps and stuff like that.
Right.
So Granian lives in that sort of bubble behind Nginx typically, right?
Use it other ways?
Yes and no, meaning that you can also deploy it like on the edge.
So I think it really depends how your structure, let's say your code.
So, so for instance, like for Vue applications, like in Django, we
tend to, I mean, we open like offload, let's say static file serving to
Nginx since we already have Nginx somewhere relying on some, you know,
headers we sent to the response that Nginx actually parse and understand what to do.
So in general, if you don't need that kind of optimization, let's say you can
still use Granian like even on the edge, because I mean, it supports like SSL.
It supports like HTTP2 directly.
So, I mean, having Nginx above Granian makes sense only if you want to root
something out of Granian and not, you know, serve it from Granian.
But yeah, in general, I'd say that you can use it in both ways behind Nginx or
not, up to the specific needs of the application, let's say.
Yeah.
I have one Nginx Docker server container handling like 15 different apps.
And so for me, that's kind of the setup, but typically the SSL that I do is over
Let's Encrypt using Certbot.
If I want to do HTTPS with Granian, how do I do it?
You can keep like the Let's Encrypt and the ACME-SH generation thing because
Granian supports the sigap signal.
So whenever you need to refresh the certificate, you can issue a sigap to
the Granian process and that process will reload the workers picking up the new
certificate.
So I think it's pretty straightforward.
I mean, if you already manage like SSL certificates and like renewal chain and
all that kind of stuff, it's pretty straightforward to do the same in
Granian.
You can just pass, you know, the paths to the certificates, to the CLI command or
even use environment variables up to you.
Gotcha.
Okay.
One thing that I thought was pretty interesting was the performance.
Not necessarily that it's so, so, so much faster, but that it's so, so much more
consistent.
You want to talk about that a little bit?
Yeah, so I think if you want to show to the YouTube, your audience, the
comparison thing, you find the link in the bottom of the page because the first
phase of benchmarks in the repository contains just benchmarks of Granian
itself.
Whereas in the versus page, you can find like comparison with other servers.
So the thing behind, let's say the stable keyword I used into describing like
the performance of Granian was about the fact that usually when people look at
benchmarks, just look at the, you know, number of requests.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's the max request per second you can get with this thing or whatever.
Yeah, exactly.
But the, another like very important value, at least to me, it's like the
latency because you can, you can still serve like a lot of requests in parallel,
but the amount of time each request will take to be served, it's also like
important.
I mean, I can serve like a thousand requests per second, but if those
requests takes a second or it takes like 10 milliseconds, it's like a huge
difference for the end user.
Yeah.
And so the thing is that from, from at least from benchmarks, it appears that
the way Granian it works, which relies on having like all the network stack
separated from Python.
So all the IO, the real IO part involving the network communication is not tied to
the Python interpreter.
And so it doesn't suffer from the global interpreter lock and threats getting
blocked between each other.
It seems to make like Granian to be more, let's say predictable in response time,
meaning that the, both the average latency and the maximum latency you have in the
benchmarks is much lower compared to other, let's say implementations, other
HTTP servers.
So yeah, it's not like super faster.
It won't make like, obviously it won't make the Python code of your application
faster.
We can shut down all of our servers, except for one $5 DigitalOcean server and
just.
Yeah, no, not really, but at least it should normalize in a way the response
time of your application.
Yeah.
So the standard deviation of the request time is way, way tighter.
Exactly.
The distribution of the request time is way, way tighter, even though you do seem
to have generally the fastest times.
But if you look at the difference of the average times and the max times, the
difference is a lot smaller.
It's like one, two and a half times variation versus some of the other ones
are many.
Yeah.
10X or something.
Yes.
Yeah.
Maybe a hundred X or some of them.
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's what really I've thought was pretty interesting is the super
predictability of it.
Yeah.
One thing I want to ask you about is you did say it does this RSGI.
You want to call it G, GSGI, the granian server?
No, whatever.
No, it's like a RAS, RAS, RAS server gateway interface.
Yeah.
That's, that's what I figured.
And you said Emmet uses this, which is awesome.
What's the advantage?
Is there a significant advantage to doing things differently rather than
ASGI or something?
Would it be worth like things like Flask saying, Hey, should we support this if
we're running on top of granian or things like that's what I'm getting at?
So I didn't actually know if Flask today also supports a synchronous.
With court they do.
A request.
I'm not.
Yeah.
Okay.
So quartz might take advantage of RSCI, meaning that is still asynchronous
protocols, so you have to be in an asynchronous context to use RSGI.
But the main difference, let's say between ASGI and RSGI is that it's in the, how to
say the communication mechanism, or let's say the communication entities, meaning
that, so in ASGI you have usually have two methods, two awaitable methods, which
are like send and receive, and you get or push, let's say dictionaries to, to those
methods, which are referred as messages.
So usually have like a dictionary, which has type key, which contains like the
type of message, which might be, I don't know, HTTP request or HTTP body or web
socket message and all the intercommunication between like the server
and the application relies on those dictionaries with specific keys and strings.
And since you have like a single, let's say interface to rely on that, and that
interface is asynchronous, it also means you, it means two things.
The first thing is that every time you want to say something to the server or to
the clients, you have to await for that message, even if there's no actually
IO involved in that operation.
So,
right.
Which is a context switch and overhead and all of that stuff, right?
Exactly.
So for example, when you, so sending back a response in ASGI involves
typically at least two messages.
So the first one is to start the response.
So you instruct the server with the response code and the headers you
want to send back to the client.
And the following message or messages are the body of that response.
The fun fact is that the response start event doesn't involve any IO at all.
It doesn't use the network.
So what happens in that is that you delaying the operation that you are supposed
to do, which is just saying, okay, I'm gonna send some data and these are the,
like, here's some text.
Yeah.
You're going to delay that operation to the next cycle of the
event loop in your Python code.
So that adds quite a lot of overhead.
And I mean, I understand like why the interface is made in this way, because
it's like super straightforward, it's very simple, you have like the
same interface to do everything.
But at the same time, it feels very unperformant in a way because
we are wasting like a ton of like, even, I don't understand why do we need
like to waste event loop cycles to do something that is actually synchronous code.
Yeah, sure.
And so our SGI changed this in a way that you have interfaces which are
synchronous or asynchronous, depending on what you're actually planning to do.
For example, like if you have the entire body, so if your route returns, I
don't know, a JSON stream, okay, you don't need to actually await for sending
the body because you already have like all the bodies.
So the interface in R.
Right, right.
It's all in memory.
Yeah.
There's no IO.
The interfacing.
It's not like a file, file stream point or whatever they said to return.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So in that case, in RSGI, you can use a synchronous method to just move the body
to the server and just let the response goes.
Nice.
Whereas if you want to stream content, then you can use a specific interface
for that in RSGI, which is RESTfulStream.
And that gives you like an interface to send chunks of body or iterate over
something as you're supposed to do.
Oh, yeah.
So that's the major thing.
The other thing, like the other reason why RSGI exists is that.
Yeah.
ASGI is designed based on the fact that the network communication happens under
Python, which is something that Granian can do because can emulate because it
supports ASGI, but that also makes that also waste.
So if you have the chance to have a different implementation that makes like
things a lot more difficult to implement, meaning reasoning, like if you were in
Python, but you're actually in a different language.
So yeah, that's the other reason why RSGI exists.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's very interesting.
And maybe some of the other frameworks could look at that and go, well, if
it's available, it's an option.
Okay.
A couple of things I want to talk about before we run out of time here.
One is Jazzy Coder out in the audience asks, how did you validate your
library following the correct spec?
Did you reference the RFCs or another library or if you can use a go down
back to principles of the Unix networking programming book and for a background
interested in this approach, cause I'm building my own WSGI server.
Okay, cool.
So the idea, I mean, WSGI protocol is like documented in a PEP.
So I just implemented tests that respect what is defined into the original PEP
about WSGI with just an exception.
So the only exception in for Granian in WSGI protocol is that it's able to serve
HTTP/2 over WSGI, which is not supposed to happen, but with Granian you can serve
your WSGI application directly with HTTP/2.
But yeah, that's the way I was sure to respect the protocol.
Yeah.
How about like the HTTP/2 protocol?
Are you using just a library that already has it all figured out or?
Yes.
I mean reinventing the wheel, like also for HTTP handling was
something I wasn't looking for.
No, I wouldn't want to do it either.
So yeah.
Hyper, hyper is again, super battle tested is used by, I don't know, something
like Cloudflare in production.
So.
And this is a rest crate or something like that?
Yeah, exactly.
Awesome.
All right.
Very cool.
The other thing I want to ask you about, or just let you speak to real quick is
there's a bunch of features like specifying the HTTP interface level.
Like, do you want to restrict it to one or two?
Yeah, you might care because there was a vulnerability in HTTP/2 create like a,
some kind of too much work or too many retries or something recently.
So maybe you want to switch it to one for a while.
I don't know.
Fun fact, the Granian wasn't affected by that because hyper, the library behind
it wasn't affected by that back.
Oh, nice.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I figured basically you just, in this case, you wait until hyper either fixes
it or hyper is not a problem, right.
Which is great.
But maybe just talk about some of the things that we haven't touched on that
are interesting, like blocking threads or threading mode or, or
specifying the loop or so on.
So yeah, Granian.
So since Granian has this unique architecture where you have an event
loop running on the Rust side.
So for instance, if you're like deploying your ASGI application with
Granian, you will have two event loops, like the Python one, the ones that
runs your code and also a Rust event loop, which is actually the Tokyo runtime
is another super popular crate in the Rust ecosystem.
There are different way to run the Rust runtime, meaning that Rust is not
limited to having a single thread running the loop and thus you can have an event
loop running on several different threads on the Rust side.
And so the threading mode option in Granian lets you specify that behavior,
meaning that if you use the runtime option, you will end up having like
multi-threaded runtimes on the Rust side.
Whereas if you specify the workers option for the threading mode, it will still use
a single threaded runtime also on the Rust side.
If you say though, the runtime mode, did the workers themselves
each get multiple threads?
Is that how that works?
Yes, exactly.
So in runtime mode, every worker has multi-threaded runtimes.
Whereas on the worker side, you have like the worker is also the runtime.
Yeah.
Got it.
And the option is there because like depending on the load of your
application, like one of the two might work better.
Sure.
Depends on the IO and CPU boundness of your application.
So yeah.
I don't want to go into too much into these, but if I set the
threading mode to runtime, is it reasonable to have just one worker?
Or does it still make sense to have multiple workers for a pet run up?
So the thing is that with a single worker, so the workers will spawn their
own Python interpreters, so every worker is limited to the global interpreter
lock, meaning that even if you spawn like a single worker with, I don't know,
12 threads, those 12 threads we run in the Rust code, but they share a single
Python runtime, which means all the things that that means.
Exactly.
Got it.
Okay.
So the only way to scale, so the workers is the way to scale, let's say
the Python code of your application.
Okay.
Threads and threads are useful to scale the Rust runtime of stuff.
No, there are some, the Rust side of stuff, of the things, meaning that
those will be like the amount of threads used by Rust to handle your requests.
So for example, if your application runs, opens like a tons of websocket,
maybe you have like a websocket service, it might be helpful to spawn more threads
for the Rust side, so it can actually handle more of those requests in the
websocket lane and the blocking threads are mostly relevant only for the WSGI
protocol, meaning that the blocking threads are the amount of threads used
by Granian to interact with Python code.
So on ASGI, since you will have like the event loop, there's no so much
difference in how many threads you, how many blocking threads you spawn,
because those blocking threads will still have to schedule stuff on the Python
event loop, but on WSGI, since you don't have, you're not limited to
the main thread of Python.
So if you're, I don't know, maybe your application is using, you're using
CypherPG to connect to the database and those libraries are able to release
the global interpreter block.
So having multiple blocking threads on WSGI might be helpful, still be
helpful because like all the code, which doesn't involve the GIL will
be able to run in parallel.
Right.
Maybe one part, one thread, one request is waiting on a database call, which
it hits the network, which releases the GIL, for example.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Okay.
What about this loop optimizations?
This opt, no op.
Yeah, that's, that's.
What kind of magic is in there?
Uh, that's a bit complicated, meaning that, so I think like writing
runnion was like super helpful for me, at least to understand like the
internals of asyncIO in the Python world.
And if I have to be honest, I don't really like how asyncIO is implemented
behind the loop, but anyway.
I feel like you have to juggle, you have to be so aware of what loop is running.
Has a loop been created?
Is there a different one?
Have I got the wrong loop?
Like all of that stuff, it should be utterly transparent.
And I just, I should just tell Python, I want to run stuff in a loop.
Yeah.
You know, I don't want to, it's not like I'm managing the memory or juggling,
you know, the GC, like, I feel like asyncIO should be the same.
You should say, I want to run stuff asynchronously and maybe somewhere I've
configured that, or maybe it's automatic or whatever, but just do any, you're
always kind of like, you know, for example, if you talk to the database
asynchronously at the start of your web app, and then you use FastAPI and you
try to use it in your requests there, it'll say, well, you're on the wrong
event loop.
It's like, well, why do I care about this?
Just run it on the loop.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like that's kind of, that's been a complaint of mine since three, five, but
Hey, nobody asked me.
So.
Yeah.
So yeah.
And those, let's say optimizations are actually a few hockey parts.
In fact, like I think like FastAPI doesn't work with loop optimization
enabled with Granian because it skips.
So those optimization just keeps like one of the first iterations into running
asynchronous code.
I think going more deeper than this in details would be.
Yeah.
Okay.
Not, not worth it.
Right.
Long and hard to follow, but let's just say it just keeps some steps
into the task running in the other loop.
Yeah.
Okay.
You can do things like specify the SSL certificates and stuff.
This one right here is pretty excellent.
I mean, I don't know who worked on that one, but I didn't work out, but I
inspired, I requested this one as the right way to put that you can say the
process name, which is nice.
Yeah.
If you're running multiple sites all on Granian on the same server, so you can
differentiate which one is using the memory again.
And while we're looking at this, can I ask, can I propose an idea and just get
your feedback on it and get your thoughts?
What about a lifetime management type of feature where you say after 10,000
requests, just recreate the worker or after an hour, recreate the worker
or something like that?
Is this a thing that is in any interest to you?
I understand the need for that, especially for, I think it's like one of those
requests that is based on the fact of using like WSGI or at least like it's
coming more from the Django user land.
So I think making a lifetime, that kind of check would be kind of hard in a sense
that there's a lot like involved into the, you know, process management of
Granian because like, you know, the Python process and then you have Python
threads and then you have like the Rust threads and then you have like the
runtimes and then reasoning of lifetime probably it's kind of hard.
I think like the fixing like a maximum number of requests per worker is
something it can be done, let's say pretty easily.
That issue is like, it's opened by, there's an issue for that, like open by
a few times, if I recall correctly.
The thing is that like in the, let's say in the prioritization queue,
it's not at the top.
So let's say at the moment, like I'm talking with some people that propose
their self to join as a contributor on Granian, but let's say at the moment,
I'm still like a single main contributor.
So yeah, sure.
I need to make, you know, some priority queues into issues.
I'll look after your wellbeing.
Yeah.
I think like the one which is more requested right now is like the access log.
So I think like that would be the next one probably.
Yeah.
I think honestly, that's more important of the access log than this one.
There's something changed in one of my apps and it just all of a sudden
slowly just keeps growing in memory.
And I'm pretty sure I've not done anything to make those changes.
And it's something in a third party library, data access
database or something else.
I don't know what it is, but it's just, and it's fine, but it's consumed so much
memory and so I ended up setting up some other thing to just say, look, after like
a day, just, you know, just give it a refresh, let it refresh itself.
You know that with Sentry SDK now we have also profiling, so you can actually look
into the stocks of memory allocations, even like live on your application.
So if you need to debug something like that, you can try with Sentry.
Like distributed tracing or something like that.
Yeah.
Or the APM stuff.
No, I mean, distributed tracing is more like about chaining together, like
different sources, like this is profiling, like.
The APM.
Yeah.
Okay.
Flame graphs and stuff to see where does your application.
Maybe I'll put it in because it's driving me crazy and I would love to just do a PR
somewhere and just go, Hey guys, this changed, here's the problem.
Or if it is my problem and I just like, there's nothing I really changed in the
core of this thing, but it seems to have started going weird that maybe I don't
know, but anyway, it would be great.
I'll have a look at it.
Thanks.
All right.
What's next for Granian?
Yeah, I think like fulfilling a couple of feature requests, like the access log,
like the worker, a max request or a few, let's say minor things in that sense.
I think like in terms of major features, it's pretty solid at the moment as a
server after, let's say the idea is like after these feature requests, the idea
was to, I mean, it's just an idea at the moment, but I'd like to try to add some
features to the RPSGI protocol.
For example, we talked before about channels and WebSockets.
So as I said before, like I find very annoying, like every time I want to make
even just a chat room, I need to, you know, put Redis there and manage Redis
and whatever, and add like that kind of complexity to my project.
And so I was thinking about like embedding some broadcasting features
into the RPSGI protocol, because, you know, while all other servers for Python
are written in Python, and so they're like still bound to, you know, the process
paradigm of Python on the rough side of things, that's not true anymore.
So.
Right.
Yeah, it would be to have something to broadcast messages between processes
and even different granular servers.
So.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah.
That's what I have on my table at the moment.
All right.
Well, excellent.
And thanks for working on this.
It's an excellent project and it's really cool to see like kind of the
innovation, like you were saying just there, you know, if it's not in Python,
if it could be in Rust, like what would we change that would make that more
capable even for the Python people, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And I think it's like the, I think it's like the baseline philosophy of people
like Samuel Colvin with the Pydantic project, like to, you know, to try to
empower Python, like the most keeping like the simplicity and the syntax we
all love about Python, but I think it's like a very good way of evolving
even the Python language.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, sometimes you'll hear people say Python is slow and then like in
some sort of pure sense, that's true.
But then, you know, you put it on top of things like gradient and all
of a sudden it's awesome.
Right.
So thanks for playing your part in that.
Thank you too.
Yeah, you bet.
And thanks for coming on the show.
I'll see you next time.
Thank you.
Bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python to Me.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Be sure to check out what they're offering.
It really helps support the show.
It's time to stop asking relational databases to do more than they were
made for and simplify complex data models with graphs, check out the
sample FastAPI project and see what Neo4j native graph database can do for you.
Find out more at talkpython.fm/neo4j.
Want to level up your Python?
We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video
courses over at Talk Python.
Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced
topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight.
Check it out for yourself at training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show.
Open your favorite podcast app and search for Python.
We should be right at the top.
You can also find the iTunes feed at /iTunes, the Google Play feed at /play,
and the direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days.
If you want to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air,
be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Thanks so much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
Now get out there and write some Python code.
[MUSIC]